you
everyone is cherrymon leeches org and
going to play a 5-2 game against John
maggle all right let's try d4 and c4
alright Grune felled or Kings Indian
Kings Indian it is alright let's see
what we get
Oh Knight d7 lets castle let's close it
up and now what Queen c2 yeah let's
develop and defend e4 and let's do this
stops Knight h5 and looks to challenge
the knight as soon as he moves I'm
looking at night to d3 let's go straight
in guess I'll be taking with the bishop
Knight takes Knight they may allow me to
just take and they'll recapture at the D
pawn because that gives up this that
gives the knight is square in d6 maybe
I'm alright with that I could look to
undermine the e5 pawn that would be one
of the drawbacks yes it opens up a new
spot for the night but he's a little bit
more vulnerable so anyhow I could have
captured and then looked at some f5
strike at some stage so I know fide I'm
thinking f4 I think it's important I do
this yep let's do it
don't want to
for by black and then this squeeze
against my king so let's open it up I'd
like to have all these pawns exchanged
okay how to recapture probably with the
knight I don't want to deal with Knight
to f6 with tempo on my bishop this is an
open position let's take some care over
those bishops I thought the other
capture with maybe g5 f4 was an idea
that they're just going with the solid
move I don't want to take because rook
takes rook and I have to under develop
so let's get a Bishop move in where does
he belong I guess here so that I can
consider a capture and then challenge
the bishop on e6 I'd really like to have
this guy exchanged now I should consider
this I don't see any reason not to go
straight in for this let's do it now
that my rooks are connected let's open
this physician up
let's forget that pre move-in maybe even
Bishop g5 is an idea if they're not
careful
yeah I'm really eyeing up the bishops
III they did capture their pointing at H
to g5 forces their queen to a pretty
awkward square actually am I not just
winning now Bishop g5 and then queen f2
to f7 how do you stop that yeah I don't
think you stopped that I'm also you've
been threatening me an FA this must be
right
queen c8 a must has otherwise I get to
f7 and I'm hitting a loose piece okay
actually what am I talking about Queen
here Bishop f5 I could do this though
this must be correct Queen f2 let's just
go straight in for it could get there
dark
bishop if the night here and I think
they have to move the night hmm
Bishop g7 might hold although I could
give a check Queen e7 and then think
about this or even rook to f8 in fact
yeah Bishop g7 Queen f7 King h8 Queen e7
threatens rook f8 Bishop takes Queen
takes me the knight has no moves really
if I could control these two squares of
the knight is dead and if the knight
can't move these two don't see the world
over here on the Kings side so control
the night and you control these two
major pieces as a way to view it okay
give a check or go straight in for
Knight here Queen check first seems
right alright let's see if I could see a
tactic for once just there's something
juicy here man there's something juicy
here will he spot it Queen f7 King h8
Knight f6 that Bishop isn't is pretty
short on squares actually now that
should do it then Queen f7 King h8
Knight f6 I'm on the bishop twice if he
goes here I have Queen f8 mate if Bishop
takes Bishop Bishop takes and that's
deadly Queen check first and then they
to f6 and the knight is also paralyzed
at that stage is he not Queen f7 Knight
f6 if the knight moves I have may here
these checks are nothing I just move in
the corner let's do it and they'd have 6
just
checking here I have some time to do it
Knight f6 actually a knight f6 Bishop f5
now that's not working
they'd have six Bishop f5 I could just
take in it but at the very least damage
their structure and they can't take I
feel like I've already missed something
that was more convincing mm-hm I didn't
see the knock out I feel like I'm
already past the knockout stage well
there might be another knockout but I
feel like I've already missed something
good but let's try to stay focused here
Bishop f5 what will I do I believe just
take and I think that that's their only
move Bishop g4 I could just capture and
then there's mate with Queen of fate rip
takes
I only need a rook here to deliver mate
at the end this night takes away that
flight square so I guess that this is
what they're considering Bishop g4 as
well I'll just take right away there in
the think tank less time than me it's
nice this is just losing right away
can't get out of that pin if my bishops
on this diagonal Bishop f5 Bishop f5 it
is um how about I take and then play
Knight d7 what does that even do let's
start with this and maybe this move wow
they're considering oh they're either
considering a checker that must be the
only other move what else could they be
considering because I've made on each
seven so Bishop h6 Bishop takes Knight
or Queen of fate hmm
okay okay well I don't think I have I'm
not seeing anything here and I guess
they're gonna go for a queen trade now
with Queen of fate
yeah so I'm still the better side but I
don't know I guess I have to exchange
Queens now sad but I believe true sad
but true
also my night runs the risk of getting
trapped Bishop d4 check now man should
have never gotten this far okay my night
is not gonna be trapped now he's got c6
I want g3 King G - this is tough to
fight back from I must say like it's
just psychologically when you know that
something was there and you have to play
out this this end game which is still
favorable for white no doubt you know
they have a fee and cut out night maybe
this is a move at least get my knight in
to play with tempo against their bishop
given time I just want g3 King g2 and
I'm happy I'll take these small little
details think tank here we go control
that night keep him fiend cut out let's
see if I could catch a tactic later if
he even gets to that point they're
running low on time here they're eight
Knight do something dangerous hmm boxing
out my knight again are you
I think my knight will be good here and
where do we want to go let's keep this
square under control don't allow this
didn't see that move keep pressure on
that pond
oh man okay can I not win that pond now
maybe I want to kick their kingdom back
some first mm-hmm think about the e6
square that cuts off their brook I think
the night has to return to g7 it's not
going there stay inactive night f4
they're gonna play some pawn move hmm
let's go here Wow why am i pulling my
knight away here it's a nail-biter it's
a nail-biter
okay the H file is opened up let's get
over here enter on the 7th how about
that
or maybe even over here there's an
opening file don't forget about that
threatening to maybe take the night and
land a fork alright I could give this
check let's get right here get in that
pond oh let's just step up first I guess
they're gonna get that guy huh I was
ready to get made into its rook to e4
Wow a night ending get to take this pawn
and defend c4 and even hunt down the F
pawn they're right we're getting there
we're getting there okay he's a long way
off from getting my Jeep on now I think
I could go in this direction and I
should have this in time let's push this
one he's really fast
all right he's just letting me Queen
let's give a check go in there hmm
let's go here and push this
they're designed for a second I thought
I was down on time good grief
messy man messy it's not it's a win but
it's a win that feels no good there's no
satisfaction whatsoever from this game
mmm
what
stockfish tell me tell me what I missed
okay I'm fine with how the opening
played out this reaction to f5 playing
f4 is fine I know it is if I'm not
reacting like this I have to deal with
this kind of shutdown of the center and
then this caveman-style attack against
my king just launching pawns and going
right after my Kings throat so how do
you stop that you meet fi with that for
he and open up the position Knight takes
c6 just be half punish advantage just
because of this guy giving some weight
to the d5 pawn anything mr. own here I
don't think so Queen c2 defend z4 this
Knight reposition it's fine and I like
the timeliness of it too because I don't
want to deal with Knight h5 because once
he's there then I have some concern of
f4
don't want to play this because I weak
in my light squares so 91 right now
Queen c2 I played excuse me I play Queen
c2 they played a five so if they're
doing this right away I could give him a
boot so one side if any four they then
stabilize their night position and now I
do this just before they play Knight h5
drawing some attention to that move
order there suggest capture first and
then f3 okay so this is another one to
be aware of not playing f4 because they
could play here and it's closed but
instead this really quiet move but f3
stops this pawn from going any further
and keeps pressure on f5 which means
this night will struggle to get back and
play
cuts off the connection with the rook if
he goes there
I could slowly improve like this maybe
even there's ideas connected with King H
one and then G for breaking down these
light squares
okay noted you can go for this capture
and then this early patient
modest-looking f3 okay I just played f4
it's now even takes takes did I miss
anything
I must have okay now it's on advantage
v6 seems fine mm-hmm maybe a little too
slow get this night right back into play
that's an improvement for black instead
of v6 this is aimed at preventing a c5
pawn break although I don't know if I
would really be going for that and
there's some drawback in that d5 is then
sensitive for me it may turn out to be
poison these are just general
considerations you know Bishop maybe
depending the Queen to the king at some
point if he has taken to work it out
work it out precisely of course Tokai b6
stop c5
take upon and a half advantage how could
I've done better I played Bishop g5 it's
fine with that
and now queen f2 is winning what did I
miss
+5 Queen f7 so far so good
hmm wants it go within the bishop to f6
plus 5 Wow okay I went with the night
what's the trick here Bishop takes
Knight takes in the help Bishop here
okay so suppose they do this right now I
have this aren't they getting a trade-in
though oh my god
that's tough to see this rook up and
I I could do without my queen who needs
her hmm this night two squares away from
the corner square he is a beast and a
half who needs a queen Knight and rook
oh that's pretty sweet
didn't see this idea of a rook left I
figured my queen would be challenged in
short order with bishop here takes takes
you know they have the f5 square and
this slow
well not slow but this quiet move rook
f3 to h3 you figure in the meantime your
queen is going to be exchanged and then
you have you know you've missed your
chance for a tactic but there's still a
tactic there rook f3 Queen FA rook h3
and that's the ball game
it's mate it's just it's mate you can't
do anything about it right here you take
take me Wow nice okay this is something
I I will remember these these things
these little motifs here these little
configurations a knight fiend cut out
like this and night here it's a little
rook lift that's sharp
yeah alright well I went in with the
night instead and now it's still fine
pawn and a half advantage but clearly
not as decisive as Bishop f6 so far so
good with the knight f6 move and now
rook lifts yeah this is where I got
nervous I'm like okay my queen is soon
to the Queen's are soon to be exchanged
I don't want to have to deal with being
down upon but I guess it's still calling
out for this rook lifts not as decisive
in this case Queen f8 rook here they
could now take the knight out
Queen takes Queen takes bishop takes
still the better side a space superior
minor piece better structure but yeah
yeah this is pretty good could even
improve the King this might even be a
one King and pun ending even just trade
not entirely sure but at least I have
the choice okay well what more to say I
played be three queens are now off I
started to have some fear of getting my
knight trapped my king is flushed to the
corner my knight finally gets back
involved I nearly fell for Mia one I
nearly fell for a million one it's
holding his upon advantage less than
that yep right around here I nearly fell
for a mate plus two uh-huh and I hear
rook here Knight f3 with the fork rook
here we could give a check hmm you could
give another check King takes Knight h4
King here I take the knight and then on
to pac-man mode the rook is out of play
tough to see that at this point we're
playing off of the increment it's even
and where did I almost fall for that
mate right around here I was ready to
take here that would have been painful
that would have been very painful glad I
didn't do that and rook takes instead in
this night ending will be very difficult
for black to try to hold
yeah tough to play accurately in these
night endings so a little time but in
the end it is working out get the Queen
and yeah they're not going to be in time
I have to get back data always pre-move
to Queen or always promote to Queen
pushing through okay well I had my
opportunities there with the Bishop f6
move instead of Knight to f6 from a
tactical you know a tactical note from
this one is
Bishop to f6 with this rook lift idea
and the positional thing I'm taking away
at least one of the positional things
I'm taking away is this idea of simply
taking and then if pawn takes you have
this f3 move this modest restricting
type move still keeping the center fluid
and slowly then building up Bishop d2 I
imagine and I think an active plan again
is something related to King h1 in g4
maybe even first rook g1 and then g4
going after the King I didn't look at
this but I guess the other capture of
course is for black to go like this well
what could I do in this case I could
operate on the e4 square they give that
up if they're not taking with the ponic
and operate on the e4 square it popped
up for a second f3 it's also considering
that with maybe f3 know how big a fan I
think I'd be looking more more the long
along the lines of let's say developing
rook here in maintaining my control over
E for yep okay well some interesting
ideas that I learned in this one hope
you took a thing or two away from this
one as well and feel free to leave any
feedback in the comments section below
as usual I hope you got something out of
it that's all for now take care bye
you